if I asked you where gasoline comes from
it's dinosaurs right fossil fuels dug
out of the ground but it doesn't have to
be see it's possible to make gasoline
synthetically using this this and a
little bit of energy you're gonna have
to trust me here they're known as
e-fuels and the people who make them
believe that they could provide a carbon
neutral way to power combustion engines
without having to dig up oil giving a
second clean life to gas guzzling cars
planes and trains but re fuels really
carbon neutral and will we be using them
to cleanly power our cars in the future
let's find out
so the gas that I've just put in my car
is made of hydrocarbons hydrogen and
carbon two elements that are pretty much
everywhere carbon is in the CO2 that I'm
breathing out and hydrogen is in H2O
water but how on Earth do you turn air
and water into gasoline
to answer that I've come to synthetic
fuel startup zero here the company is
building a small development line where
they say they'll be making 20 liters
which is around 5 gallons of synthetic
fuel a day for testing and certification
their CEO is this man padilo who you may
recognize from his many years as
technical director for a string of
Formula One teams when we burn a
hydrocarbon we produce carbon dioxide
and water and all we do in our chemistry
is put those back together again sounds
simple right well it's not first you
need to extract hydrogen from water
here's Zero's director Professor Nile
Shah the water is electrolyzed where you
put the water into unit and you combine
that with an electric current and it
splits the water back into hydrogen and
oxygen you then need to isolate CO2 from
the air using a carbon capture unit like
this one at Imperial College where
Professor Shah teaches so now we have
carbon dioxide and hydrogen and those
form the starting materials for the next
part of our process now zero told me
this part is somewhat proprietary but
essentially the CO2 and hydrogen are
converted using pressure and heat into
H2O and hydrocarbons which you can then
turn into jet fuel Diesel and good
old-fashioned gasoline there is no limit
because there's no digging anything
under the ground everything comes
literally from the atmosphere and goes
back there when you're finished with it
and while that may have been a very
simplified explanation of a very complex
scientific process it's not exactly a
new principle after all during World War
II the vast bulk of Germany's aviation
fuel and half of its gasoline came from
synthetic fuel manufacturing so if it's
possible and has been for quite some
time why aren't e-fuels everywhere well
firstly there's the energy required to
make them every step of manufacturing
synthetic fuels can be quite energy
intensive and you get a lot less energy
out than you put in our Target is for
about half the energy that you put in as
electricity
to end up as the fuel that's LED some to
question why you would use the fuel for
cars when batteries can be more
efficient then there's the carbon
neutrality for e-fuels to be truly
carbon neutral their creation has to be
powered by sustainable renewable sources
like solar and wind and then there's the
tailpipe environmental groups point out
that while synthetic fuels can create
less emissions than fossil fuels they
still create more tailpipe permissions
than an EV which doesn't have a tailpipe
at all finally there's cost right now
this whole process isn't cheap to put it
into perspective Zero's limited edition
first batch of its fuel which is more of
a souvenir than anything else runs at
just over 200 a gallon though Paddy
assures me those prices will come down
we anticipate that uh we will be making
synthetic fuel at Cost parity with
fossil fuels within a decade so will we
be driving synthetic
in their future well it depends who you
ask see in the EU they've granted an
exemption for e-fuels in the Block's
2035 ban on sales of new internal
combustion engines which basically means
that automakers can continue to sell gas
cars providing they only run on e-fuels
wsj reporter Bill Boston covers autos
and lives in Berlin there are going to
be millions of cars on the road from
many years to come that have combustion
engines they believe that e-fuels is a
way to keep those cars on the road
um and also lower emissions at the same
time however when it comes to investing
in e-fuels if you follow the money the
amount of investment going into it does
not compare in any way what the industry
has already invested in the last 10
years to develop electric vehicles so
why did the EU throw its weight behind
e-fuels well the reason could have a lot
less to do with the environment and a
lot more to do with the fact that
Germany's main export is cars there are
so many jobs that depend on making
engines here in Germany of the around
000 jobs directly related to auto
manufacturing 447
000 of those jobs are linked
specifically to the internal combustion
engine so what does the future hold for
e-fuels well while it's likely you'll
see them powering planes and trains in
years to come that high cost means that
it's unlikely you'll see them powering
the average family car for quite some
time
thank you
[Music]